bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat mercredi les sénateurs
ont adopté le projet de loi créant les
contrats d'avenir une promesse de
campagne de françois hollande qui vise à
favoriser l'embauché de jeunes en cdi
tout en maintenant les seniors dans
l'entreprise alors au sénat l'ensemble
des groupes de gauche a voté pour ce
texte à les sénateurs ump ont voté
contre
quant aux centristes ils se sont
partagés sur ce projet de loi
certains parmi les plus optimistes ont
souhaité et votez pour qu'un ils se
disent préoccupés par la situation de
l'emploi tandis que d'autres soucieux et
inquiet du financement de ce nouveau
dispositif ont préféré s'abstenir
alors tout de suite retour sur le vote
de ce texte bonne après midi à tous sur
l'article 6 demande de plus de bandes
masquées
vous avez la parole mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 6 de ce projet de loi a
notamment pour effet de reprendre les
dispositions prévues à l'article 1er un
1er bis et et résulte de l'adoption par
l'assemblée d'un amendement déposé par
le député serge letchimy et son groupe
demandant la réalisation d'un rapport à
destination du parlement sur les
modalités de mise en oeuvre du contrat
de génération dans les départements et
régions d'outre-mer au rhino semble
qu'en l'état actuel de sa rédaction le
projet de loi ne prévoit pas des
modalités d'application particulière
pour les dogues puisque les contrats de
génération s'appliqueront de plein droit
en guadeloupe en guyane à la martinique
et la réunion
les seules règles particulières figurant
en réalité à l'article 4 et concernent
exclusivement mayotte dont le droit au
travail connaît certaines spécificités
aussi cette disposition qui revient à
demander d'évaluer les conditions
d'application d'un dispositif pour des
territoires donné alors que les règles
en vie
sont celles qui s'appliquent à tout
toute la france nous apparaît curieuse à
moins que des dispositions dérogatoires
surprise par voie réglementaire mais
auquel cas il serait opportun que le
gouvernement nous a menés forme les
disant cela je ne nie pas les
singularités des départements et régions
d'outre-mer
mais j'avoue mal cerné la portée de
cette disposition
je le dis d'autant plus volontiers que
les difficultés que connaissent
certaines de ces territoires sont
énormes
il y à peu mon collègue et ami paul
vergès m'a fait part de la situation
particulière et dramatique que connaît
l'île de la réunion
il nous a notamment rappelé que durant
les cinq ans du mandat présidentiel
entre 2012-2017 sa réunion comptera
cinquante mille habitants de plus si
aucune mesure d'ampleur n'est prise dans
tous les secteurs les problèmes seront
amplifiées lille subit déjà un taux de
chômage de l'ordre de 60% soit 160 mille
demandeurs d'emploi un chiffre qui
compte tenu du nombre de jeunes
bacheliers dix mille par an environ est
appelé à croître et ce d'autant plus que
comme la métropole n'est plus durement
encore les entreprises réunionnaises
sont frappés par la crise le taux de
chômage des jeunes y était
malheureusement des records puisque
malgré les diplômes près de 23000
réunionnais de moins de 25 ans étaient
privés de travail à la fin du mois de
décembre
cette précarité sociale accrue est
d'autant plus insupportable qu'il ya à
la réunion des inégalités de revenus
très importante au point que beaucoup
évoquent cette situation en parlant d'
apartheid social
aussi monsieur le ministre au nom de mon
collègue permettez moi de vous demander
si des mesures spécifiques seront
effectivement prises pour les dom et si
oui lesquelles est qu'ils puisent et il
semblerait qu'en 2013 le nombre de
contrats aidés soit en nette diminution
par rapport aux années précédentes
alors même que le chômage connaît un
taux d'augmentation continue
là encore nous souhaiterions savoir
quelles sont les mesures que vous
entendez prendre pour soutenir l'emploi
à la réunion et dans les dom en général
tu es ma chère collègue
à cet article il ya un amendement numéro
63 présenté par madame de mantet sous le
nom de la commission des affaires
sociales vous avez la parole oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
il s'agit effectivement d'un amendements
rédactionnels qui stipule que c'est la
promulgation de la présente loi et non
pas l'entrée en vigueur mais je voudrais
profiter de ma parole sur cet amendement
pour en rappeler ce que nous avons voulu
faire au niveau de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat sur cet
article 6 et pour relever ce que dit
notre collègue isabelle pasquet dans cet
article nous avons souhaité regrouper
dans cet article 6
leur rapport à compter du 30 juin 2014
le rapport du gouvernement déposé au
parlement chaque année à partir de 2014
sur la mise en oeuvre du contrat de
génération
avec toutes les précisions je n'y
reviens pas ça a été un site est tout à
l'heure nous n'avons pas voulu faire un
cas particulier parce que ça n'est pas
un cas particulier des départements des
régions d'outre-mer pour autant
effectivement jeu à la relecture de
cette de cet article on a l'impression
que l'alinéa 2 présente les modalités
d'applications spécifiques du contrat de
génération dans les départements et les
régions d'outre-mer
donc je pense et on pourra peut-être le
faire pour la commission mixte paritaire
je pense qu'il faudrait rédiger de
manière un petit peu différente l'alinéa
2 en disant par exemple que si dans ce
rapport du gouvernement au parlement
chaque année on veillera aux modalités
de mise en application à la mise en
oeuvre du contrat de génération
dans ces départements et ses régions
d'outre-mer voilà et puis nous avons
souhaité rajouter dans l'alinéa 3
quelque chose sur lequel un certain
nombre de collègues sont revenus pendant
nos débats qui s'achève
la question de l'opportunité de modifier
éventuellement les conditions d'âge ce
qu'on a appelé dans le débat les bornes
d'âge et il nous a semblé que c'était
important que trois ans après l'entrée
trois ans après la promulgation de la
présente loi on puisse évaluer aussi
cela merci
merci ma chère collègue pour la défense
de l'amendement revo explications
monsieur le ministre à vis du
gouvernement sur l'amendement numéro 63
oui monsieur le président la vie du
gouvernement est favorable c'est un
amendement de rédaction mais je voudrais
aussi pouvoir apporter quelques éléments
de réponses aux questions qui ont été
posées par madame passiez qui sont des
questions tout à fait légitimes alors je
vais être très claire aujourd'hui comme
vous l'avez dit vous-même
il n'y a pas de dispositions
particulières pour la plupart des des
dom enfin certain nombre de spécificités
outre-mer dont il conviendra de tenir
quand on pense en particulier à mayotte
donc ya pas de mesures spécifiques je
voudrais insister sur un point
c'est certainement dans ces départements
d'outre-mer que le contrat de génération
peut s'appliquer le plus rapidement et
le plus généralement beaucoup ils sont
très intéressés et sont très intéressés
d'abord parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes au chômage
donc évidemment là où il ya le plus de
jeunes au chômage c'est quelque chose
qui va pousser à l'embauché de ces
jeunes et il ya aussi des jeunes en
situation de qualification qui sont au
chômage donc c'est vraiment pour tous
les jeunes
et la deuxième chose et plusieurs ou
ultra marins ont insisté sur ce point
ce sont aussi des territoires où il
existe beaucoup de petites entreprises
de parfois de très petites entreprises
et où la question de l'arrivée du jeune
dans l'entreprise et quelque chose
absolument crucial y compris dans le
cadre de cette modalité particulière du
contrat de génération qui est la
transmission de l'entreprise et donc
beaucoup m'ont dit oui on l'a vraiment
s'intéresse énormément
on va beaucoup se battre pour faire
connaître le dispositif sur ces
territoires là donc je pense que ce sont
des territoires qui vont
considérablement pouvoir bénéficier ou
mettre en oeuvre avec dynamisme le
contrat de génération
deuxième chose nous avons pris la
précaution c'est l'article 6 auquel vous
fait des références de prévoir qu'il y
aurait une analyse plus particulière
pour le 30 juin 2014 de la situation
dans l'outre-mer parce que
il n'y a pas de disposition particulière
aujourd'hui mais il ya malgré tout une
situation particulière et donc il est
nécessaire de vérifier au bout d'un an
d'un peu plus d'un an
si la situation particulière est en
adéquation avec le fait il n'y a pas de
disposition particulière et nous aurons
donc à ce moment là avec les données
statistiques qui seront nécessaires la
possibilité d'apprécier et
éventuellement de modifier le dispositif
c'est donc exactement de cette manière
là que le gouvernement cherche à vous
apporter une réponse à un enjeu
considérable lutter contre le chômage
des jeunes dans ces territoires
ultramarins et favoriser un vrai
développement économique en profondeur
qui permettent de l'activité de la
création de richesses et donc de la
création d'emplois dans ces territoires
qui en ont bien besoin
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
mettre voilà maintenant numéro 63 qui
est pour son adoption
qui est contre l'amendement est adopté
jumelles aux voix l'article 6 qui et
pour qui et contre l'article 6 est
adopté
nous passons à l'article 7 avec
l'amendement 45 rectifiée présentée
pendant manade debré collègues en
commission un amendement du rapporteur a
été adoptée supprimant un dispositif
d'aidé à l'embauché des seniors
demandeurs d'emplois créés lors de la
réforme des retraites de 2010 en raison
de l'absence de décret d'application de
ce texte
cependant ce dispositif reste un bon
moyen d'insérer les seniors moins
complexe et mieux cibler que les
contrats de génération puisqu'il permet
d'augmenter le nombre d'embauchés des
seniors et non simplement de maintenir
en activité ceux qui ont un emploi
il faudrait réactiver ce dispositif en
aucun cas
en tout cas le supprimer si ma chère
collègue avis de la commission c'est le
président de ce ministre mes chers
collègues donc l'amendement de 45
rétifié de madame debré visa à maintenir
un dispositif des dalles embauche des
seigneurs que nous avons supprimé en
commission
moi j'entends bien ce que vous dites
madame debré mais depuis 2010
il n'y a jamais eu de décrets
d'application donc il n'y a pas eu de
volonté de ce dispositif des aides à
l'embauché des seniors donc il n'est
jamais trop tard mais il le décret
n'étant pas paru je vous propose donc de
revenir sur l'article 5 qui supprime un
dispositif des aides à l'embauché des
seniors qui n'a jamais été appliquée
depuis 2010 donc c'est un avis
défavorable de la commission des
affaires sociales merci madame là à
porter monsieur le ministre à vis du
gouvernement
mais monsieur le président c'est vrai
qu'il est difficile de pouvoir constater
l'efficacité d'un dispositif qui n'a
jamais été mises en oeuvre et donc de
pouvoir constater le caractère nocif de
la suppression d'un dispositif qui n'a
jamais été mise en sommes mais surtout
madame parce qu'au fond je pourrais
comprendre votre raisonnement s'il est
bon qu'il n'a pas été mise en oeuvre par
vous même par votre majorité pourquoi ne
le feriez vous pas aujourd'hui
il ya donc une autre raison en dehors de
celle ci qui est une raison de bons sens
c'est que y'a le contrat de génération
et que le contrat génération et bien
entendu le dispositif que nous
souhaitons privilégier pour la mise en
oeuvre des politiques en faveur de
l'emploi des seniors
beaucoup d'entre vous d'ailleurs 10 et
on dit dans ce débat attention à pas
multiplier les dispositifs a pas faire
ce millefeuille comme on a trop
l'habitude de faire en france un
dispositif plus un autre plus un
troisième puis un quatrième à la faim
plus personne n'y comprend rien donc
nous avons le contrat de génération qui
simplifie qui réunit en un seul document
plusieurs négociations qui existait
auparavant qui permet aux entreprises de
bénéficier d'une aide importante pour le
jeune comme pour le plus âgé
y compris l'embauchent que vous savez
d'un plus âgée à 55 ans puisque c'est
possible en appareillant avec un jeu
donc nous privilégions la simplicité et
l'efficacité sur la multiplication des
dispositifs inopérant et mon cher
collègue pas de demandes d'explications
de vote
je vais mettre aux voix l'amendement 45
rectifié ayant reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre l'amendement n'est pas
adoptée j'aime et aux voies l'article 7
qui et pour qui est content l'article
cet état
d après l'article cet amendement numéro
57 présenté par le gouvernement monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole il
s'agit monsieur le président d'une
disposition spécifique pour l'outre-mer
donc ça nous allons dans le sens qu'ils
avaient été souhaitées mort c'est un peu
technique vous m'excuserez mais
l'article 3 de la loi du 27 mai 2009
pour le développement économique des
outre-mer a créé la possibilité pour les
employeurs implanté dans une région un
département d'outre-mer à
saint-pierre-et-miquelon saint-martin
saint-barthélemy dans lequel un accord
régional ou territoriale
interprofessionnel a été conclue selon
les modalités prévues à l'article l 22
32 du code du travail
donc le possibilité de verser à leurs
salariés un bonus exceptionnel d'un
montant maximal de 1500 euros par
salarié et par an je crois que chacun se
souvient dans quelle condition ce bonus
avaient été mises en oeuvre à la suite
de grandes difficultés sociales dans ces
territoires
alors il se trouve que ce dispositif a
bénéficié d'une prolongation d'un an que
cette prolongation elle-même vient à
échéance et donc il vous est proposé de
prolonger une nouvelle fois le titre des
bonus versés pour une cinquième année et
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2013 au plus tard
voilà l'objectif de cet amendement qui
permet de prolonger encore pendant un an
nous verrons au delà le dispositif du
bonus outre mer merci monsieur le
ministre madame le rapporteur monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
on l'a vu à l'instant dans le débat sur
l'article 6 qu'il n'y a pas de règles
particulières dans les départements et
dans les régions d'outremer et en
métropole par contre il y à une
situation socio économique très
différentes et notre collègue antoinette
hier soir dans son intervention il a
fait largement allusion en particulier
sur les taux de chômage qui sont
multipliés par deux ou trois quelles que
soient les catégories d'âge concernée
donc je pense qu'il fait effectivement
que nous
pouvons qu'être d'accord avec la
proposition du gouvernement de prolonger
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2013
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
concernant le bonus exceptionnels versés
aux salariés dans certaines
collectivités ultramarines et d'ailleurs
cela avait fait l'objet d'une rencontre
emploi où trop mère qui s'était déroulé
en juin 2013 va donc assez récemment
donc je propose un avis favorable de la
commission sur cet amendement
mais merci qui souhaitent s'exprimer
monsieur dés ce plan vous avez la parole
alors bien sûr monsieur le ministre je
suis favorable à ce que nous puissions
le projet disons le versement de cette
prime
je suis là certainement train d'enfoncer
une porte ouverte mais je voudrais bien
assurer effectivement que nous que vous
plongez cela pour les mêmes raisons que
moi je prends acte de cet amendement qui
en outre mer permettra aux employeurs
versant une prime de continuer à
bénéficier d'une exonération de charges
sociales pour notre maximum de 1600
euros par an et par salarié contourner
la difficulté financière ou de biens des
entreprises ultramarines
je comprends la volonté du gouvernement
de prolonger à nouveau de quelques mois
un dispositif provisoire qui avait été
élaboré en 2009 pour aider à apaiser de
graves troubles sociaux à la suite
d'accords régionaux interprofessionnels
sur les salaires l'état s'était alors
engagé à accorder pendant trois ans des
exonérations de charges sociales aux
entreprises ultramarines contribuer au
versement d'une prime exceptionnelle à
leurs salariés
et ça c'était au csg crds et forfait
social
ce dispositif représente depuis sa
création un coût de l'ordre de 30 à 40
millions d'euros
il faut dire que le gouvernement
précédent avec lui à l'époque quelques
mesures de sortie de crise sans pour
autant agir efficacement sur le fond les
choses
heureusement depuis en charge et ainsi à
l'initiative du ministre victorin lurel
une loi contre la vie chère outre-mer a
été votée en novembre dernier
destiné à faire baisser les prix entre
30 et 50% plus cher que ceux de
l'hexagone en corrigeant les situations
de monopole ou de lio paul et renforcer
la transparence des prix nous avons volt
est longue et les finances des
dispositions favorisant la compétitivité
des entreprises en allégeant le coût du
travail
nous sommes en train aujourd'hui de
faciliter l'embauché des jeunes tout en
maintenant des seniors dans l'emploi
deux catégories de salariés particulier
et pour le chômage dans nos territoires
ultramarins l'ensemble ces initiatives
devraient produits ou ses effets dans
les prochains mois en tout cas en 2014
aussi je formule le souhait qu'il
suscite un nouveau modèle économique
plus dynamique est favorable et qui
permettra d' le plus projet au delà de
l'an prochain un dispositif conçu je le
répète comme provisoire merci beaucoup
merci mon cher collègue pas d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote
alors je mets au voile amendement numéro
57 delà du gouvernement qui avec un avis
favorable de la commission qui est pour
son adoption
qui est contre l'amendement est adopté
je vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
oui madame debré vous avez la parole si
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues d'avoir un
constat nous regrettons vraiment qu'un
seul de nos amendements identiques à
celui de monsieur mézard était adopté
tous nos autres amendements ont été
rejetés
le groupe ump votera contre ce projet de
loi
nous voulons tout d'abord dénoncé je
crois que j'ai fait beaucoup preuve de
respect vous pourriez juste avoir le
même
nous voulons tout d'abord dénoncé la
divergence entre les annonces faites par
le gouvernement et les effets que l'on
peut raisonnablement attendre de ce
dispositif
la majorité annonce en effet cinq cent
mille créations d'emplois au moyen de ce
contrat ce qui semble tout à fait
impossible selon les prévisions
économistes
de plus deux tiers des emplois prévus le
seront par un effet d'aubaine
c'est à dire qu'ils auraient été créés
de toute façon effet d'aubaine qui je l'
ai déjà rappelé fut dénoncée en son
temps par plusieurs personnalités de
gauche pendant les primaires socialistes
autre point le contrat de génération
reposait sur l'idée séduisante de
solidaires
tu es entre les générations mais le
texte prévoit aujourd'hui que
l'accompagnement du jeune parent
référent ne se fera pas forcément par le
senior de son binôme et mieux encore ne
sera peut-être même pas fait par un
senior de l'entreprise quant aux
entreprises
ce texte leur fait subir des contraintes
des contrôles et les expose à des
sanctions supplémentaires
nous voulons également dénoncé le coût
très important de cette mesure
un milliard d'euros par an en rythme de
croisière
force est de constater que la nouvelle
majorité multiplie les dispositifs au
lieu de renforcer ce qui existe déjà et
qui ont déjà fait preuve leurs preuves
telles l'inca l'alternance et
l'apprentissage
le contrat de génération ne prévoit que
très peu de choses pour la formation des
jeunes qui seul peut leur permettre
d'accéder durablement à un emploi enfin
nous contestons le mode de financement
choisi
il reposera sur le cic le crédit d'impôt
aux entreprises créé en décembre par le
gouvernement qui se trouve de ce fait
déjà amputé avant même d'avoir été mis
en oeuvre
en conclusion je dirais monsieur le
ministre que nous attendons ce que nous
attendons c'est que vous engagiez les
réformes d'ampleur nécessaire pour
donner aux entreprises les moyens
d'embaucher et non pas malheureusement à
la multiplication de dispositifs
hasardeuse je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue la parole à
monsieur vergoz bon explications de vote
ce président est monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
heureusement que nous avons agi monsieur
le ministre
depuis neuf mois il y a neuf mois
seulement nous étions dans le trou
marcheurs collègues et se trouve pas
santé madame la condition que vous
vouliez prendre l'échelle qu'envoûtant
pour le prendre pour en sortir nous
étions dans le trou parce que nous ne
ressentions plus encore en outre-mer que
dans l'hexagone parce que comme l'a fort
bien répéter la rapporteure tout à
l'heure vos chiffres
dans l'hexagone ils sont trois fois
inférieurs aux nôtres
on y reviendra je me félicite monsieur
le ministre que nous ayons agi pour que
enfin la boîte à outils soient complètes
sur la question de de l'emploi alors je
viendrai pas sur le 6 et le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi
tout le monde se félicite de cette
grande avancée la banque publique
d'investissement qui est touché un bel
outil mais je resterai sur eux les
contrats les emplois et je voudrais
m'opposer à saké dit une de mes
collègues madame basket tout à l'heure
par rapport à la baisse des contrats
aidés c'est un premier outil non pas
chaque collègue
nous avons voté au plf 2013
des chiffres élevés de contrats aidés et
j'aimerais que dans cet hémicycle
si à la réunion on peut entendre au
contraire je peux encore l'admettre 9000
kilomètres nous séparent
mais ici dans cet hémicycle j'ai voté le
même plf que vous et des contrats aidés
ont été à un niveau élevé
trois cent quarante mille 6e de mémoire
50000 ses yeux c'était le chemin ouvert
à la nécessité d conserver un niveau
élevé nous avons eu en plus un deuxième
outil nouveau qui est le nôtre l'emploi
d'avenir
cent mille en 2013 est déjà opérationnel
dans nos régions
hélas dans certaines moins que dans
d'autres et puis là ce soir le contrat
de génération quête boîte à outils
quelle boîte à outils jamais nous
n'aurions pu obtenir ces choses-là yam
il ya neuf mois
donc soyons fiers de ce que nous faisons
j'invite les uns et les autres qui
traîne un peu les pieds de de se joindre
à nous parce que les uns et les autres
nous agissons dans l'intérêt
de notre jeunesse et de ceux qui vivent
tous les jours l'exclusion c'est à dire
la possibilité de réaliser aucun projet
de vie tout simplement parce que le
matin quand ils se réveillent ils ont
rendez vous avec le néant
ça c'était la réalité ici comme chez
nous en outre-mer alors je me félicite
de cette boîte à outils nouvelle
d'autant plus heureux que chez nous
madame la rapporteur a raison soixante
pour cent des 15 à 24 ans sont au
chômage
60 chez vous 24 permettez moi chez nous
ici dans l'hexagone 24%
on joue pas dans la même cour le taux de
chômage ici 10% et on s'affole chez nous
chez vous aussi l'outre-mer vous y êtes
maintenant processia je vous y invite et
mille fois 30% des taux oui oui madame
vous avez une courte mémoire mais je
vous attends et pour que vous imprégner
de la réalité ultramarines on vous a pas
tout fait visiter je poursuis je
poursuis mes collègues en vous disant
que nous nous félicitons ultramarins
beaucoup plus que vous pourrez ce soir
ressentir de fierté vous mes collègues
qu'ils allaient voter cette loi
alors monsieur le ministre nous pouvons
en être satisfaits mais pour autant
est-ce que c'est gagné mais pas du tout
mais pas du tout et là je suis bien
d'accord avec vous
le président de la république
reconnaissons le a tenu ses engagements
le contraire eût été bien étonnant de ne
pas nous retrouver aujourd'hui avec la
le vote sur cet outil
le gouvernement les a mis en oeuvre ses
engagements du président de la
république on est dans la logique du
travail parlementaire
le parlement précisément les a mis en
musique ses engagements et il nous reste
quoi maintenant mes collègues et c'est
cela le principal
la principale difficulté il nous reste à
à faire vivre
cette loi a fait revivre ses avancées
ses lois et cela n'est pas facile je le
reconnais parce qu'il nous faudra
entraîner l'adhésion de nos partenaires
naturels que sont le chef d'entreprise
faudra bien qu'il retrouve son compte et
je laissais particulièrement intelligent
j'en suis et j'en rencontre
ils connaissent ils connaissent leurs
intérêts ne les faisons pas passer pour
plus bêtes qu'ils ne le sont ensuite
s'agissant les emplois d'avenir par
exemple les mairies les régions les
départements les associations je sais
que certains traînent les pieds
parce que au prétexte que ce serait pas
leur loi merci appropriez vous là c'est
la loi de la république
elle appartient à notre jeunesse elle
appartient à tout le monde qui peut dire
ici ou là que nous pourrions dans la rue
croisé un jeune avec aucune perspective
lorsqu'il se réveille et se dire oh mais
moi je suis un élu de droite je ne je
n'ai pas d'emploi d'avenir prauthoy
parce que c'est là l'emploi d'avenir
françois hollande seront d'où aussi
ridicule que cela je ne le crois pas je
conclu monsieur le président en dix ans
la jeunesse de france nous regardent
celle de l'outre-mer également ne la
trahit sont pas prenons nos
responsabilités
et pour ceux qui traînent les pieds les
citoyens seront les reconnaître
merci mon cher collègue la parole à
madame françoise laborde
j'avoue qu'après vous chers collègues
mais je vais être donc très brève merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre et donc chers collègues
donc ce projet de loi met en oeuvre des
engagements du président de la
république et il répond à deux défis du
marché du travail d'une parlant gauche
du jeune en cdi pour accéder à un emploi
stable
d'autre part le maintien dans l'emploi
des salariés âgés
nous devons nous en féliciter les
travaux de l'assemblée nationale et de
notre assemblée ont contribué à
améliorer un texte qui rappelons le
reprend fidèlement les termes de
l'accord national interprofessionnel
signé le 19 octobre dernier par
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
je profite de cette occasion pour saluer
monsieur le ministre votre méthode de
travail qui marque une véritable rupture
avec le passé vous laisser large place à
la négociation sociale
nous ne pouvons que vous encourager dans
cette voie monsieur le ministre les
contrats de génération vont dans le bon
sens c'est un signal fort que nous
adressons aux français touchés durement
par le chômage
nous le savons bien nos jeunes sont
touchés plein fouet près de 27 % d'entre
eux n'ont pas d'emploi et ce qu'ils en
trouvent enchaîne bien souvent stages
cdd et missions d'intérim moins d'un
jeune sur deux bénéficient d'un cdi
les seniors ne sont malheureusement pas
mieux lotis puisque la probabilité de
retrouver un emploi à quelques années de
la retraite est particulièrement faible
après les emplois d'avenir ce texte
symbolise votre détermination à lutter
contre le chômage
et c'est donc cet esprit que le rds vous
apportera son soutien et qu'il votera à
l'unanimité ce texte
merci ma chère collègue la parole à
monsieur gattolin merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre chers collègues le contrat
de génération qui nous est proposé ici
est une opportunité et une très belle
opportunité de réconciliation
générationnel
au sein de l'entreprise j'insiste sur ce
point parce que lorsque l'entreprise
avec les partenaires sociaux et les
relais lundi institutionnels s'engage
sur la place des seigneurs et
l'intégration des jeunes en son sein
elle promeut une vision moderne de
l'entreprise celle d'une entreprise
citoyenne garante d'un développement
durable exonérés d'une vision court
termiste est capable de se projeter dans
l'avenir et dans celui de la société en
mettant l'accent sur le transfert des
compétences et l'accès à la formation
dès le recrutement
le contrat de génération remet l'accent
sur les savoirs collectifs savoir mise à
mal par les effets délétères du travail
précaire et de l'atomisation de l'emploi
le contrat de génération s'inscrit
également dans une orientation une ligne
est européenne le parlement européen
vient en effet d'adopter une résolution
relative à la garantie européenne pour
la jeunesse visant à permettre aux
jeunes au chômage depuis plus de quatre
mois de se voir proposer un travail une
formation ou un apprentissage ce texte
appelle les ministres de l'emploi de
l'union européenne a adopté une
recommandation du conseil en février
2013 c'est-à-dire ce mois ci afin de
mettre en place ce système dans tous les
états membres
nous devrions logiquement soutenir la
mise en place de ce système n'est ce pas
car l'urgence française que nous non
d'étudier notamment auprès de la
jeunesse renvoie à l'urgence européenne
près de 14 millions de jeunes de moins
de 30 ans en europe ne sont ni dans
l'emploi ni dans une formation
le coût de cette mise à l'écart est
estimé à 150 milliards d'euros par an
pour l'économie européenne soit
davantage que le seul budget de l'union
européenne au sens global du terme la
mise en place de la garantie jeunesse
coûterait seulement 21 milliard
cette initiative fait donc écho aux
propos que nous avons tenus lors de ce
débat garantir aux jeunes l'accès à
l'emploi faire la chasse aux statuts
précaires et en premier lieu aux stages
qui trop souvent encore remplace des
salariés sur de vrais postes et de vrais
emplois
alors oui nous écologistes nous
soutenons le contrat de génération y née
sans doute peut-être pas parfait il
devrait être amélioré mais le mini
donc sa méthode et dans les propositions
qu'il a faites à proposer dans réévaluer
les effets les conséquences et ça c'est
une chose positif nous soutenons le
contrat de génération parce qu'il s'agit
d'une véritable loi d'intérêt général
elle s'inscrit dans une logique louable
de transmission des savoirs
d'apprentissage durable et solidaire du
savoir faire alors je voudrais au delà
du soutien des écologistes lancé un
appel à ma collègue et ami
alto-séquanais si la belle debré qui est
tout à leur évoqué les contrats
d'apprentissage en alternance
lancé par le précédent gouvernement je
le dis j'aurais été dans cet hémicycle
je les aurai soutenu je fais depuis des
années des masters professionnels avec
l'alternance avec le contrat
d'apprentissage en alternance
on a vraiment gagné en sécurisation de
l'emploi un emploi sur deux dans des
métiers relativement peu recherché se
traduisent par des contrats à durée
indéterminée et je lui dis ça parce que
justement je pense qu'à un moment il ne
faut pas avoir une regard je dirais
complètement idéologique ou de positions
politiques je crois que ce que nous
avons en face est du même ressort il est
dans l'intérêt général l'intérêt général
comme construisons où le savoir se
transmet ça prend de manière humaine et
je crois que tout ça se complaît je
crois qu'il faudra ajouter sans doute à
terme aux prochaines étapes chez que
nous révélions nous retravaillons j'en
ai parlé avec plusieurs sénateurs ici
l'usagé qui est fait du 1 % formation
dans les entreprises parce que
effectivement il ne remplit pas
pleinement ses fonctions il repose sur
une partie on pourrait qualifier de mai
utilisation de l'argent donc je crois
qu'avec ces fameux contrats
d'apprentissage en alternance avec ses
contrat générationnel est une véritable
refonte repenser de lui l'argent qui est
utilisé par les contrats a parlé elle
les amplis 1% formation en entreprise
nous pourrions ensemble tracer les voies
d'un apprentissage d'une connaissance
d'une entrée dans le marché qui soit
enrichissant à la fois pour ceux qui
entrent pour ce qu'ils sont et pour ceux
qui en sortiront je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole à
monsieur kerdraon
oui monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre juste quelques mots
puisque beaucoup de choses ont déjà déjà
été dit et notamment mettre beaucoup de
passion et d'enthousiasmé
tout à l'heure pour vous dire tout
simplement pourquoi le groupe socialiste
votera ce texte vous l'avez compris avec
enthousiasme et fierté enthousiasme et
fierté tout simplement parce que
effectivement c'était un engagement du
candidat françois hollande s'était
rappelée par madame debré tout à l'heure
et j'ai peut-être tendance à penser elle
a évoqué les primaires j'ai tendance à
penser que c'est peut-être aussi un
élément qui a fait qu aux primaires ça
lui a permis de tout à fait madame debré
c'est un texte qui répond à une double
urgence une urgence sociale et
économique tout simplement le
sous-emploi structurelle des jeunes et
des seniors
c'est aussi et je voudrais le rappeler
salué la méthode qui a été initiée par
ce gouvernement
dix ans dix mois pourrait faire là la
comparaison 10 ans d'absence quasi de
dialogue social et la en dix mois
le travail a été fait avec les
partenaires sociaux travaillent
d'ailleurs qui est complémentaire de
celui que nous faisons ici il ne
faudrait pas que l'on oppose qu'on
essaye de poser le travail que réalisent
les partenaires sociaux et le travail
que nous réalisons ici au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale c'est aussi et ça
a été dit à plusieurs reprises dans ces
débats on a parlé de boîte à outils tout
à l'heure c'est effectivement un outil
novateur au service de la lutte contre
le chômage
alors bien évidemment cet outil seule ne
suffira pas on a parlé des emplois
d'avenir
d'autres dispositifs vont venir bientôt
mais quel chemin parcouru en dix mois
quel chemin parcouru et c'est pour ça
que je parlais tout à l'heure de fierté
autre élément qui fait que le groupe
socialiste votera ce texte tout
simplement le changement de vision le
changement de regard qu'offre cette
démarche et ce texte
on n'oppose plus les jeunes aux seniors
on est bien sûr une véritable alliance
des âges autre élément peut-être à
mettre en évidence
autre élément à mettre en évidence c'est
aussi le rôle et la remise au centre
aussi de l'entreprise car mesdames et
messieurs de l'opposition les
socialistes et la gauche ne sont pas des
ennemis des entreprises ça a été très
bien dit par michel vergoz tout à
l'heure au contraire mais nous sommes
effectivement pour quelque chose pour
des relations équilibrées sereine et
honnêtes et transparentes et je veux
à travers ce projet ce dispositif saluer
tout particulièrement le dispositif qui
permettra de transmettre pour un artisan
de transmettre son entreprise à un jeune
et ça c'est quelque chose qui chez nous
est aussi particulièrement attendu enfin
pour conclure je dirais que ce texte est
un dispositif pragmatique il offre une
cohérence au choix de notre majorité
en matière d'emploi c'est un signe tout
simplement d'espoir c'est un signe de
soutien
et monsieur le ministre votre
gouvernement
notre majorité redonne aux jeunes et aux
seniors une véritable utilité sociale
alors oui nous voterons ce texte avec un
grand enthousiasme et beaucoup de fierté
merci mon cher collègue la parole à
monsieur marseille
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
souscrivons pas au plan global que vous
proposez pour chercher à inverser la
courbe du chômage en 2013
nous pensons que les emplois d'avenir
dont nous avons beaucoup parlé ici
aurait dû être beaucoup plus largement
ouvert au secteur marchand
il aurait alors très bien compléter le
dispositif des contrats de génération
ces derniers semblent en plus adapté
pour les tpe et les grands groupes
tandis que les emplois d'avenir serait
mieux calibrée pour les entreprises
intermédiaires mais vous n'avez pas fait
ce choix vous avez fait des emplois
d'avenir de classiques emploi parapublic
et ce à l'heure où il n'est plus
question que de réduire les effectifs de
la fonction publique
de même nous ne pouvons que regretter
l'institution du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi qui aura des effets
différés en lieu et place des baisses de
charges et de la tva compétitivité qui
elle aurait eu des effets immédiats
comparé à ces deux dispositifs en soit
le contrat de génération nous paraît
beaucoup moins critiquable
comment ne pas souscrire à la
philosophie qu'il sous-tend le
déplacement de l'opposition des
générations sur le marché du travail le
plus il s'agit d'un dispositif
susceptible de générer de l'emploi
pérenne puisque réservé au secteur
marchand est précédé d'un accord
national interprofessionnel
enfin nous pouvons que saluer l'avancé
que nos débats auront permis de réaliser
en termes de formation des jeunes peu
qualifiés embauchés en contrat de
génération en revanche nous redoutons
que le contrat créé par ce texte les
deux générations que le nom il part d'un
bon diagnostic
la difficulté pour les entreprises de
dégager du temps pour accueillir les
nouveaux arrivants et d'une belle idée
le lien intergénérationnel en entreprise
en revanche le contenu de ce texte peine
à lui donner du sens le projet ne
garantit aucun lien intergénérationnel
entre les deux membres du binôme de
l'accueil du jeune et de la transmission
des savoirs et des compétences qui fera
quoi
c'est un mystère ce qui vous en
conviendrez constitue un problème de
plus nous trouvons particulièrement
préoccupant le financement du dispositif
par le séisme d'autant qu'il finesse ce
sont les collectivités qu'ils
financeront puisque un doublement de la
baisse
hors dotation semble programmé pour les
années à venir
au terme de ce débat et je pense que
chacun a eu à coeur avec les convictions
qui sont les siennes de chercher à
améliorer ce texte
notre groupe et partager les plus
optimistes soutiendront le texte parce
qu'il espère qu'il favorisera l'emploi
dans notre pays
d'autres plus préoccupé par la nature du
dispositif s'abstiendra je vous remercie
mon cher collègue la parole à monsieur
des plans
monsieur le président madame rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes collègues
ultramar et moi même avons souligné à
mettre reprises lors du précédent débat
que dans nos territoires les plus
touchés par le chômage que de nos
territoires les plus touchés par le
chômage sont les jeunes actifs de monde
et 30 ans en guadeloupe le taux s'élève
à 46 pouces en 1 je me suis au but et
poulet nos diplômés ce chiffre dépasse
les 60 de poussan mais il faut souligner
le chômage des seniors
il faut souligner le chômage des seniors
est aussi le réalité aux antilles
toujours en guadeloupe il a augmenté de
14% un an
c'est sans compter les seniors
découragés qui ne font même plus les
dimanches pour recherche d'emploi même
s'ils souhaitent vers votre travail et
8,8 seniors au chômage ou 10 le sont
depuis plus de luz ont proposé un
contrat destiné à inciter les
entreprises à la fois à la bouche de
jeunes et au maintien des seniors est
donc bien une belle idée pour reprendre
l'expression du président hollande
inattendu je voudrais donc en faveur du
projet de loi
les deux hommes ont d'ailleurs
expérimenté il y a quelques années un
dispositif ou un lien jeunes les seniors
initié par la loom sous le gouvernement
jospin par la convention entre le
département la région et l'état
il favorise le départ en pré retraite
des salariés de plus de 55 ans et le
remplacement par les jeunes de moins de
30 ans il avait ainsi permis de créer un
deux ans plus de 500 emplois en
guadeloupe avant que la majorité
parlementaire de droite ni mettre fin en
malgré la crise et l'emploi salarié
privé enregistre des progressions dans
certains secteurs de montagne de mon
département ceux du bâtiment de
l'industrie agro alimentaire
ils activités financières et d'assurance
la contrat de génération pour un bloc
constitué une réelle opportunité de la
gauche pour l'heure aux entreprises qui
sont toutefois pour la quasi totalité
d'entre elles des pme ou de tpe comptant
peu de salariés
je souhaite préciser en outre que le
contrat génération concerne le secteur
privé en guadeloupe
les seniors sont surtout présents dans
le secteur public et parmi les
indépendants
j'ajouterai deux observations la
première concerne l'obligation pour les
entreprises qui souhaitent bénéficier du
dispositif d'être à jour de leurs
obligations envers les organismes de
recouvrement de cotisations et des
contributions de sécurité sociale ou
d'assurance chômage
or dans les dom les dettes sociales les
entreprises sont considérables tout
comme celle des collectivités
territoriales et des établissements
publics d'ailleurs pour la seule
guadeloupe elle s'élève à un milliard
d'euros
on ne va me parle presque car les
entreprises implantées sur le territoire
tout ce qui a été mis en place pour y
pallier n'a jamais abouti au résultat
escompté est de fait beaucoup
d'entreprises n'ont pas pu bénéficier
des exactions des paroles ita après les
événements de 2009
parce que ces aides étaient conditionnés
à la mise à jour de cotisations sociales
je pense par exemple aux aides à la
rénovation hôtelière alors même que le
tourisme est un élément important de nos
économies il s'agit là d'un phénomène
structurel particulier aux territoires
ultramarins qui appelle une étude
approfondie et une solution juridique
adapté je connais que cette obligation
soit un frein au succès du contrat de
génération
en outre mer deuxième observation
le dispositif du contrat de génération
est basée sur le dialogue avec les
syndicats ce qui est une très bonne
chose
c'est l'occasion à nouveau pour moi de
souligner comme je l'avais fait quand
nous avons discuté en décembre dernier
de la composition des comités régionaux
d'orientation de la banque publique
d'investissement la particularité les
antilles des organisations syndicales
fortement légitime un terme l'adhérent
active est capable de mobiliser
largement était un interlocuteur
incontournable à l'échelle locale mais
qui tiennent à conserver l'autonomie et
à ne pas s'affilier à des centrales
nationales
elles ne peuvent donc pas siéger dans
l'ombre d'instance mais ce même si elles
sont majoritaires il faudra donc à tenir
compte lors du bilan sur la
représentation syndicale envisagé par le
gouvernement dans les prochains mois
voilà je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole la
parole est à monsieur watrin oui juste
quelques mots pour expliquer le vote du
groupe crc nous voterons pour 7 propose
ce projet de loi d'abord pour parce que
s'en remettent en cause les prérogatives
légitime du législateur c'est la
démocratie politique dont parlait
monsieur le ministre il s'agit pour
l'essentiel vient de la transposition
fidèle d'un accord national
interprofessionnel signé par toutes les
organisations syndicales et cela l'unami
vite et donc c'est le respect de la
démocratie sociale c'est important de le
souligner car je précise ce ne sera pas
le cas pour une autre accord national
interprofessionnel celui-là minoritaire
avec lequel nous serons groupe crc en
profond désaccord donc je préférais et
le dire d'emblée mais nous voterons pour
ce contrat de génération parce que tout
le monde fait le constat est que la vie
du jeune et quand même trop précaire la
succession de contrats à temps partiel
le contrat instable franc la vie
difficile pour trop de jeunes dans notre
pays quand une loi incite au recrutement
des jeunes sur un cdi et à temps plein
bien pour nous on ne fait pas la fine
bouche c'est une mesure qui va dans le
bon sens même si elle ne règle pas tout
bien évidemment et tout le monde en est
bien conscient ici et quand une loi fait
du cdi à temps plein une norme
eh bien c'est une bonne chose et ça nous
change de certaines lois et certains
dispositifs qui ont pu être votées
précédemment et c'est une avancée que
nous voulons absolument salué par notre
vote
nous pensons aussi que c'est un texte
positif parce que il faut effectivement
changer les mentalités dans les
entreprises que la question de la
transmission des compétences et des
savoir-faire dans l'entreprise est une
question vitale pour l'entreprise
elle-même et cela passe évidemment si on
veut réussir mieux qu'aujourd'hui parce
que les accords seniors en ont quand
même montré beaucoup de limites ont été
extrêmement limités
cela passe par le maintien dans l'emploi
voir l' embauche des salariés âgés et
celles à impliquer j'espère que le
contrat de génération permettra
d'avancer sur ce point cela implique
aussi que les partenaires sociaux à
travers les accords collectifs qui
pourront je l'espère être signés
s'attaque à la question de la pénibilité
du travail en particulier pour les
salariés âgés
enfin je dirais que l'avenir de ces
contrats de génération comme tous les
textes qu'on peut être amené ici à voter
à discuter à affiner n'ai jamais écrit
d'avancé
finalement c'est la réalité du terrain
c'est l'expérience vécue qui nous
montrera si les choix que l'on a pu
faire ont été les bons s'il conviendrait
d'améliorer ce dispositif nous avons par
exemple groupe crc a mené quelques
propositions comme d'autres groupes
toutes ces propositions sont légitimes
mérite d'être regardée de près le texte
je dirais ne clôture pas les débats ce
sera le rapport d'évaluation annuel qui
permettra de voir si les choix qui ont
été faits ont été les bons certains de
nos projets ou propositions été prise en
compte d'autres pas encore mais nous
espérons que le rapport d'évaluation du
donnera raison qu'on pourra améliorer
encore ce texte
enfin pour conclure véritablement cette
mesure positive nous la saluons nous la
voterons mais nous pensons même temps
qu'elle n'aura d'effet positif que si
l'on prend si le gouvernement s'attaque
au chômage des jeunes dans sa globalité
s'attaque à la perte d'emplois
industriels à la perte d'emplois dans le
tertiaire dans notre pays est victime
c'est à dire en réalité que des mesures
structurelles soient prises aussi pas
seulement pour les jeunes et pour
remettre l'économie et notre pays dans
le bon sens pour faire en sorte que la
finance qui domine trop souvent notre
économie et bien c'est d'un peu de
pouvoir pour que l'emploi compte soit
mieux pris en compte que nos industries
notre économie puisse se développer au
lieu de régresser aujourd'hui comme
aujourd'hui puisque gelée soulignait
l'année 2012 c'est des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois qui ont été sacrifiés
bien souvent pour des raisons boursière
dans l'industrie en particulier il faut
absolument et les jeunes profiteront de
ce dispositif du contrat de génération
que s'il y a aussi des mesures plus
ambitieuses et plus structurelles qui
sont prises pour mettre fin à cette
domination de la finance sur notre
économie
merci mon cher collègue dernier orateur
inscrits me suis mirassou
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mesdames le rapporteur mes
premiers mots irons et s'adresseront à
vous pour vous remercier pour la qualité
la précision de vos réponses et en même
temps le volet pédagogique que vous avez
su déployer à l'occasion de ce débat
nous allons dans quelques instants voter
et comme d'habitude je serais tenté de
dire
deux visions vont s'afficher deux
visions différentes à la fois du monde
du travail de l'entreprise et j'ai
failli dire même également de la société
tant il est vrai que les propos
pessimistes qui aurait évoqué sur cette
aile de l'hémicycle sont relativement
éloquent mais je ne ferai pas l'injure à
nos collègues de l'opposition d'espérer
que ce dispositif échoue pour tenter
d'avoir raison en rétrospective en ce
qui nous concerne
d'une manière très claire nous faisons
le choix du volontarisme et de
l'optimisme en attendant mon tour
qu'effectivement ce dispositif arrive
dans le cadre également du plan
compétitivité emploi
dix emplois d'avenir le tout le tout mes
chers collègues sur fond de dialogue
social et de démocratie sociale qui va
permettre dur est de sortir de cette
logique infernale
on disait aux travailleurs relativement
âgées toi tu coûte trop cher et à tout
en se tournant vers le plus jeune a 10
ans tu n'es pas opérationnel et donc on
va réconcilier à travers un projet qui a
véritablement une dimension sociétale
des générations qui jusqu'à présent
était il faut bien le dire souvent
opposés et donc ne serait ce que par
rapport à ce volet là je pense qu'il est
intéressant de noter que est
incontestablement en votant ce texte
nous allons faire un saut qualitatif qui
va nous permettre comme l'a dit alors un
excellent collègue avant moi d'avancer
vers une notion de citoyenneté au niveau
de l'entreprise et vous conviendrez avec
moi
ce n'est pas la moindre des choses du
reste le texte est suffisamment précis
pour éviter les effets d'aubaine et qui
ont été évoqués tout en n'étant pas
suffisamment contraignant pour justement
ne pas obérer et bien l'effet positif
que nous sommes en droit d'en attendre
au total bien sûr faut-il se retourner
vers des secteurs d'activités que je
connais bien je pense à l'aéronautique
ou le compagnonnage précurseur a servi
aussi d'étayer ce projet je le pense et
au maire en admettant bien sur le fait
que la synergie entre celui qui arrive
sur la marché de l'emploi et celui qui
est un travailleur averti et une
garantie en termes de compétitivité et
de gains de productivité
je terminerai en évoquant un secteur qui
à mon sens n'a pas été suffisamment
évoqué où pourtant la tente et très
conséquente je veux parler des
exploitations agricoles et ce texte
permettra effectivement de donner une
bouffée d'oxygène dans un secteur qui en
a bien besoin
donc mes chers collègues vous
comprendrez facilement que à l'instar de
ce qui a été dit par mes collègues a
précédemment
c'est avec enthousiasme détermination
qu'à votant ce texte nous appuierons une
proposition maintes fois évoquée par
françois hollande président de la
république
merci mon cher collègue je vais mettre
aux voix l'ensemble du projet de loi
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par tic 36 du
règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour métro
secrétaire un bulletin blanc ceux qui
souhaitent voter contre mais trois
bulletins bleus ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir remettront bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
ok
le demande à voter
tu vu
on meurt
chan
plus personne ne demande maintenant à
voter le scrutin est clos
j'invite mesdames et messieurs les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
non
oui
elle
résultat du scrutin numéro 81 18 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi portant
création du contrat de génération nombre
de votants 345 nombre de suffrages
exprimés 326 majorité absolue des
suffrages exprimés 164 pour l'adoption
193 contre 133
le sénat a adopté le projet de loi
portant création du contrat de
génération
je passe la parole à madame demontès
rapporteur de la commission
oui monsieur le président on va pas
refaire le débat on est d'accord
monsieur le président ce ministre mes
chers collègues
on vient de voter un texte important le
contrat de génération on vient de voter
un texte qui n'est pas l'outil miracle
pour l'emploi qui est un outil important
qui crée une solidarité
intergénérationnelle dans l'entreprise
et on ne peut que s'en réjouir en se
disant que ça va marcher
bien évidemment on va pas refaire on ne
va pas refaire le débat moi je voudrais
vous remercier parce que nous avons eues
sur tous les bancs de l'assemblée
chacun a pu s'exprimer avec des opinions
différentes des points de vue différents
mais c'est ça la démocratie aux
politiques
je veux bien évidemment remercier
monsieur le ministre de sa disponibilité
pendant ces débats
je veux remercier les collègues membres
de la commission des affaires sociales
parce que je pense qu on a fait un bon
travail tous ensemble
bien sûr remercié la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la ville est bien évidemment remercier
les administrateurs de la commission des
affaires sociales qui m'ont grandement
aidé dans mon travail de rapporteur donc
merci à vous tous
merci madame demontès la parole à
monsieur des ministres c'est vous
monsieur le président je veux pas du
tout non non plus rallonger nos débats
mais l'atmosphère a été très agréable
hier comme aujourd'hui elle nous a
permis de travailler au fond à partir
d'un texte avec la volonté naturel de la
part du gouvernement de défendre son
texte avec l'apport très important du
travail en commission merci madame la
présidente merci madame
un reporter de ce travail qui a permis
aussi d'apporter des améliorations et
avec aussi des propositions venant de
tous les bancs qui nous ont permis là
aussi de faire un vrai travail
législatif sur un texte dont aucun
d'entre nous parce que nous ne sommes
pas dans le fétichisme ne considère
qu'il apporte la solution à la question
du chômage mais dont on peut les uns et
les autres même quand on vote contre
parce qu'il ya parfois les mécanismes
que j'appelle parfois un peu automatique
de vote
même quand on veut on peut lui trouver
aussi des qualités et qui apportera de
vraies réponses à la question du chômage
déjà je ne reviens pas sur les
caractéristiques de ce contrat
génération ni dans son mode
d'élaboration
ce mariage intime intelligent me
semble-t-il entre la démocratie sociale
et la démocratie politique
ce mariage cette alliance entre les âges
les plus jeunes et les plus âgés et
cette ambition qui est de faire en sorte
qu'un savoir faire une connaissance
puisse se transmettre
mais se transmettre dans les deux sens
parce que ça chacun sait qu un plus âgé
a une expérience et une connaissance à
savoir ou d'un outil mais qu'un plus
jeune peut apporter aussi aux plus âgés
une connaissance de la société et
parfois de certains outils pensons par
exemple aux outils informatiques que les
jeunes manille parfois beaucoup plus
facilement que les plus âgés ça n'est
pas le cas au sénat évidemment où tout
le monde m'a ni ses outils informatiques
avec une grande diligence et une grande
dextérité
donc je voudrais pas revenir au delà de
cela mais vraiment saluer le travail qui
a été le nôtre
monsieur le président je sais pas si mon
193 cours
c'est pas tous les jours donc vraiment
merci infiniment
d'abord au groupe de la majorité au
groupe d'une manière générale de la
gauche qui ont d'une manière unanime
appuyer ce vote remercier aussi les
groupes de l'opposition qui ont de
manière différenciée
mais apporter aussi de leur appui à ce
vote la participation aux débats
la capacité à poser des questions elles
sont légitimes toujours et je l'espère
notre aptitude à essayer d'y répondre en
tous les cas le faire avec respect pour
la démocratie tout cela a fait un très
très beau débat monsieur le président
cette bataille contre le chômage
voyons le de manière positive cette
bataille pour l'emploi
elle est évidemment de la responsabilité
du gouvernement
quand un gouvernement est en place c'est
vers ce gouvernement que chacun et
chacune se tourner en lui disant que
faites vous quelle réponse apporter vous
à la situation que je vis comme jeunes
comme plus alger dans les entreprises
qui vont mal et qui licencie comme dans
les entreprises qui vont bien où on a
envie de voir plus de jeunes venir
renforcer les effectifs
donc toutes ces questions sont légitimes
on les tourne bien entendu vers le
gouvernement les tourne aussi vers ceux
qui votent les lois donc vers vous en
vous demandant que faites-vous
aujourd'hui vous avez voté un outil
extrêmement pertinent extrêmement
adaptée à la situation du marché du
travail de l'emploi et du chômage en
france mais c'est pas simplement une
question posée au gouvernement une
mobilisation sur la question du chômage
et de l'emploi
c'est une mobilisation dessous tous et
de toutes
il n'y a pas une personne en france qui
ne tiennent pas un morceau une parcelle
même infinitésimale de la solution dans
la lutte contre le chômage
qu'on soit chef d'entreprise conçoit
syndicaliste qu'on soit salarié dans une
entreprise conçoit animateur d'une
association que l'on soit responsable
d'une collectivité locale ou que l'on
soit responsables politiques nous
détenons une parcelle de la capacité à
gagner cette bataille contre le chômage
c'est cette grande mobilisation qui a
commencé des outils sont mis en oeuvre
les uns après les autres
au fond nous avons une sorte de rendez
vous trimestriel pour ce qui me concerne
avec le céda le dernier trimestre de
l'année dernière c'était les emplois
d'avenir
le premier trimestre de cette année
c'est le contrat de génération le
deuxième trimestre sera très intéressant
aussi y compris par les débats qu'il
permettra d'avoir au sein d'eads cette
assemblée autour de la sécurisation de
l'emploi permettre aux entreprises de
s'adapter aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui en
sécurisant le parcours individuels et
professionnels des salariés ou des
chômeurs lorsque on a perdu son emploi
c'est ça l'enjeu du texte qui est aussi
devant nous chaque trimestre nous avons
un rendez vous chaque trimestre nous
construisons ensemble un outil pour
lutter contre le chômage
et c'est au bout de ces quatre trimestre
de cette année que nous encourons
ensemble je le suis persuadé réussir à
inverser la courbe de chômage et donc à
gagner la première étape la première
bataille contre le chômage
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance à
suivre l'émission parlement hebdo qui
reçoit aujourd'hui le député ump de la
haute loire laurent wauquiez bonne fin
de journée tous